your journey ends
hey everybody John lived here with Tay
and we are at the Destiny 2 gameplay
reveal event we got hands-on with the
game starting with the campaign which is
maybe the some the thing I was most
interested in seeing you got to play it
on the ps4 Pro and I got to play it on
the PC so first off how do you feel
about the campaign itself sure it's
really interesting I mean you lived in
the tower for so long it's been your hub
world very like safe spot and now it's
being attacked by the Cabal and you're
actually going through it like what's
left of it and being ravaged by cabal
and it's interesting just to get through
that um I think we talked about it or
like with each other that it felt a
little bit faster than destiny 1 it
still controls really tight and was just
wanted to kind of go through that double
door that jurors always been hanging out
in front of and it's like oh I guess
there was ramen shops behind there all
along totally yeah the controls felt
like it reminded me of like going from
Halo one to Halo 2 where it's like the
controls are still like those tight
really good controls but they're just
kind of sped up and it felt pretty good
yeah I would also say like the campaign
had like more at least this opening
mission how was spectacle to it yes like
explosions and stuff happening I was
trying to think of like a campaign
moment and destiny one that was like
this big spectacle moment and I was kind
of struggling to think of something like
quite on the level that this was so my
campaign has these kinds of big
bombastic moments throughout I think it
will feel like a pretty impressive
campaign that you know could like stand
on its own pretty well in a way that I
think the first one kind of
fell flat yeah we'll have to see it'll
be interesting I mean not only is that
just the first mission that we got to
taste but there's gonna be like porn
you're planning it seemed like new NPCs
new stories like a new map system but
you got to play on PC I got to play on
PS yeah pro I was running at 1080 thirty
what about for you yeah you're running
ten eight thirty it looked good
well it looked visually like great it
looks better than dusty one for sure
totally wrong but what about for you
yeah so I was playing it on for K I went
to the settings yeah it's like I'm gonna
check out what I'm running and it was 4k
it looked really crisp was real real
good but it was only running at medium
settings they weren't running enough to
max but it didn't look like bad or
anything like I'd say it looked as
comparable as it did playing it on the
PSP where like the textures are clearly
sharp I imagine a lot of those like
ultra settings that I was missing we're
probably more particle effects things
like that it ran at a solid 60 frames a
second it felt really really good and I
gotta say these mouse the keyboard
controls no really great it's a little
weird like trying to adjust with like
the hotkeys and that's something with
their hotkeys there pockys refined to
have just like awesome oh my man right
like you're so used to playing its
destiny like on a controller and then
like all of a sudden like oh I get to
play an awesome keyboard like or yeah
we're all these hotkeys but the good
thing too is like you'll probably be
able to you know customize those hotkeys
oh yeah I'll be able to play however you
want it was like watch the left quick
right-click but yeah it's cool to see
that it's making his way to PC it feels
just like a huge hole that was there
before you know like this whole other
set a group of people that couldn't play
the game yeah and they definitely seem
to be doing it right when we're talking
to a dead for an interview he was saying
how they're gonna have like an fov
slider and they're gonna have like ultra
wide screen support and all that stuff
the fact that is running on battlenet
which is weird like it feels so obvious
now yeah look it was when they announced
it I was like oh I should've guessed
that
yeah there's no triangle right
Division Bungie yeah it makes a lot of
sense
yeah the VESA version looks really great
when fortunately to get a capture any of
it which I'm not really sure why because
I thought it ran good I also got to try
the PC version for the multiplayer which
felt really weird mainly because the
auto assistance turned off Oh cuz aim
aim aim assist right so how he's just
can totally smoked it very much feels
like a PC hardcore shooter I think
there's gonna be like uh I think the
multiplayer ends gonna be a little more
hardcore on the people yeah I mean you
likened it to kind of like a csgo Mo's
countdown mode for me for a PvP where
there's two different basically I want I
don't necessarily won't come long sights
but you know you're basically going to
plant a bomb right it's yeah it's
basically yeah and so like one team kind
of plants a bomb tries to defend that
from the other team from refusing it and
so it kind of feels like that
counter-strike go a little bit you know
and just look like the amy and
everything is kind of leaning that way
right yeah it captured that kind of
strike feel for sure like there was the
very counter-strike moment where we had
set the bomb but that we all died but it
doesn't automatically lose because the
bomb is still going off all right
ticking faster and faster faster and
we're all sitting there being like
please just just go off and order trying
to forget it
you officiate and then of course like it
they totally just used it and we lost
but it's like it captured that exact
saying like tanks billion that like a
traditional Counter Strike mode has so I
I thought it was great yeah awesome
all opponents defeated really the only
other thing left to talk about that we
got and I guess I got to try is there's
a strike and the strike was cool I think
it's like awesome that they're kind of
starting to really play up those great
light like moments where you know
there's like this huge drill and it's
like you got to avoid it because if you
don't you're gonna get one shot and then
your team has to go revive you and if he
doesn't revive you at the right time
you're both gonna die and so and there's
more platforming yeah that feels very
rated yeah and so I feel like it's good
to kind of have the platforming to have
the layers and the different levels and
like the best example two is when you
fight the boss you're no fighting him we
kind of up top and like he's just kind
of teleporting around and all of a
sudden like oh what's going on and like
the floor just disappears oh and you
drop down and you're fighting him in
another like kind of like terrain where
there's more pillars you can hide behind
them and like kind of have to avoid this
stuff he puts on the ground and you're
like okay cool this is like a different
kind of like moment now gets this boss
and then all of a sudden guess what
there's a third floor that you're gonna
fall down to and like there was less
cover there and he was kind of circling
you and still so many stuff so just nice
to see it kind of variety in the
gameplay instead of just like oh he's
there he's gonna do something
full expunging right yeah the other
strikes I mean the strikes on previous
game were good but I think about a
minutes there sort of a predictable
rhythm vision and like you're going to
do this you're going to shoot some guys
they're gonna maybe like occasionally
there's maybe a small little objective
is a minor and then you're gonna kill
the boss this sounds like they're
definitely like pushing it forward that
sounds pretty awesome
in your face so that's all the stuff we
really got to play unfortunately we
didn't really get to check out a lot of
this stuff that really excited me in
that presentation which was like the
guild stuff the map like the the
open-world exploration like that's the
stuff that I know the quality of life
stuff they're adding to destiny that I
think is really going to improve this
game unfortunately did get a check that
out that's more yeah that's not really
good as a show here that they're saying
for the people in they buy the game
right yeah or maybe in the beta hole
maybe I know that no more orbit that's
great right yeah that's amazing yeah by
looking forward to all those stories all
those other new NPCs on each of these
for you planets we're going to get to
see but yeah I think that you're
probably gonna go PC now that you've
seen it yeah I was debating back and
forth and and now that I played on PC I
think i have to go PC awesome well stay
tuned against marcom for more continuing
coverage of destiny to tell us if you're
going to go switch to PC are you going
to stay on ps4 or Xbox one um we're
going to join the game Spock clan when
we make it we'll see thank you guys so
much and see you guys next time hold on
back there
[Music]
you
[Music]